مرحباً بالسيناتور ميرفي في البرنامج،
شكرًا لاستضافتي، أريد أن أطرح عليك
بعض الأسئلة المحددة حول
العملية ضد مستشفى ألفا
الآن في غزة، لذلك قال
مارتن غريفيث، كبير مسؤولي الأمم المتحدة للشؤون الإنسانية، إنه
لا يمكن السماح باستمرار هذه المذبحة، لقد
فعل الآخرون ذلك  لقد قمت بتعليق قوي جدًا
بشأن شيء
بدأ بالفعل في اختبار مدى تسامح
الجميع حقًا.
الآن، هل تؤيد
اقتحام إسرائيل لمدينة
أليفا، لذا دعونا نتراجع إذا استطعنا
للحظة، هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
تتاح لي ولكم الفرصة  للحديث
عن هذا أم على إسرائيل أن تدمر
قدرات حماس العسكرية أم
لا يمكن للعالم أن يسمح لحماس أن تكون قادرة على
شن هجوم كما فعلت في
7 أكتوبر أه والحرب صعبة
وكثيراً ما يتعرض المدنيون القبيحون للأذى وحماس
تجعل الأمر أسوأ بكثير أم كما  تعلمون
بدمج أنفسهم ومعداتهم
وأصولهم داخل
المباني المدنية داخل المستشفيات والكنائس والمدارس
والمساجد هذا هو
قرار حماس باستخدام البشر كدروع أم ما
قلته هو أن
عدد المدنيين الذين يقتلون
الآن داخل أه غزة  أمر غير مقبول وغير
مستدام وفي الواقع أعتقد
أنه يتعارض مع أهداف إسرائيل الأمنية طويلة المدى
لأن حماس
ستزداد قوتها إذا
ظل عدد القتلى المدنيين بهذا
الارتفاع أه لذلك أعتقد أن على إسرائيل أن
تبدأ في اتخاذ قرارات استهداف مختلفة
سأكون صادقًا معك،
لست مطلعًا على المعلومات الاستخباراتية بشأن هذا
الأصل المحدد، لكن في النهاية،
كانت أعداد الضحايا المدنيين مرتفعة جدًا وأعتقد أن على إسرائيل
أن تبدأ في اتخاذ قرارات مختلفة
حتى أثناء استمرارها في القتال  أنا
لا أؤيد وقف إطلاق النار، أعتقد أن إسرائيل
يجب أن تواصل القتال ضد حماس، أعتقد
فقط أن عدد القتلى المدنيين
أصبح مرتفعًا جدًا، هل يمكنني أن أطلب منك
توضيحًا، لقد قلت للتو أنك لا
تؤيد وقف إطلاق النار ولكنك تدعم وقف إطلاق النار لفترة
قصيرة.  - وقف الأعمال العدائية في
الواقع لقد خرجت في وقت مبكر جدًا من هذه
الحرب V معربًا عن مخاوفك بشأن
الوفيات بين المدنيين، هل يمكنك أن تشرح لي ما
تعنيه إلى متى، والآن في الفترة الفاصلة،
أنت تعرف الوقت وأنت تصف هذه
الضحية المدنية التي سيفعلها الجميع
تعتقد أن الوقت قد حان للمطالبة بالمزيد، لذا فأنا
لا أقبل الفرضية القائلة بأن
الخيارين الوحيدين هنا هما وقف إطلاق النار
الذي يبدو لي وكأنك تعرف إنهاء
القتال ضد حماس والمستوى الحالي
من الموت المدني الذي
تتحدث عنه  إن عدد الضحايا المدنيين
على أساس يومي أعلى
من معظم الصراعات الحديثة الأخرى،
لذلك بالنسبة لي، أنت تعلم أنه يجب أن
يحدث أمران: الأول نعم أنا أؤيد
وقفًا إنسانيًا من أجل إنشاء القدرة
على الحصول على المساعدة الإنسانية والغذاء
و  المياه لمواطني غزة وأعتقد أيضًا أن هذه هي
الطريقة الوحيدة لإخراج
الرهائن ولكنني أعتقد أيضًا أنه يجب أن
يكون هناك تغيير في
حسابات الضربات لإسرائيل وأعتقد أنه
كانت هناك في كثير من الأحيان قرارات تم اتخاذها
بشكل كبير جدًا  ارتفاع معدل الوفيات بين المدنيين
عند النظر إلى
أهمية أصول حماس التي
كنت تقوم بإخراجها أه لذلك أعتقد أن كلا
الأمرين يجب أن يحدث أه المزيد من
الضربات الجراحية أم مزيد من القلق بشأن
التأثير على المدنيين وأه
وقفة إنسانية إما عدة  أيام
أو بضع ساعات كل يوم حتى
نتمكن من إيصال الإغاثة الإنسانية
وإخراج الرهائن من هناك